letonia ha cumplido su amenaza y ha
dejado al enclave ruso de kaliningrado
un poco más aislado de lo que estaba
recordemos que es una región rusa que se
encuentra encajonada entre dos países de
la otan polonia y lituania no comparte
fronteras con el resto de las regiones
rusas por eso el único transporte
ferroviario que hay para llegar hasta
allí para que las mercancías lleguen
hasta kaliningrado pasar por territorio
ucraniano ahora los ucranianos no van a
dejar que pasen determinados productos
que están en la lista de sanciones de la
unión europea se trata fundamentalmente
de carbón metales materiales de
construcción y también productos
tecnológicos moscú ya ha reaccionado y
ha dicho que si lituania no da marcha
atrás en esta decisión ellos se reservan
el derecho a tomar medidas para defender
sus intereses